hey everyone
welcome to this live ask me anything
question and answers session from the
world science Fest I want to quickly
thank our our sponsors right from the
get-go this is part of the Big Ideas
series that is supported in part by the
John Templeton Foundation and we're also
supported today by public funds from New
York City the New York City Department
of cultural Affairs and partnership with
the city council and I think as many of
you know if you've been following what
the world Science Festival has been
doing since the pandemic upended our
usual rhythm of having a live event in
New York and in Australia every year we
have been developing a whole variety
of different online formats and I hope
you've seen some of the programming that
we've put out just to give you a sense
if you haven't seen some of that we just
had a a program recently on black holes
which we call seeing the unseeable this
is the results from the Event Horizon
telescope so you should check that
program out we had a wonderful
conversation with Nobel Laureate and
Templeton Prize winner Frank wilcheck
called riddles of reality where we
discussed a whole variety of different
topics from the small to the big we call
from Corpse to the cosmos
we had a program that really went to The
Cutting Edge of research in quantum
mechanics in the general theory of
relativity some of the spectacularly
interesting results about black holes
and firewalls it's called Einstein in
the quantum you see the thumbnail up
there on the screen having to do with
the ideas of quantum entanglement and
the possibility
that these ideas may give us insight
into how space time itself emerges a
very exciting conversation with leaders
in the field we've also had a variety of
programs on non-physics topics we are an
equal opportunity science programming
organization so we've had programs like
the one you see here decoding the brain
trying to really understand
the inner workings of neurological
functioning we had a program on lifespan
how to live longer and the ways in which
various researchers think that we may
accomplish that it's called lifespan
expanded and we've had other work too we
had a wonderful programs really spanning
the gamut so you guys should check all
that out but our Live Events are
carrying forward part of our mission
which is to not just sort of bring
science out to the world and an
interesting new and novel ways but to
have a dialogue
we think that having a dialogue with you
the audience is really the vital way
that people get engaged and people get
excited and stay excited about the
remarkable ideas that are happening at
the Forefront of Science and in
particular while this is a an AMA really
for anyone of course we have a
particular Focus today on high school
kids
who've been asked to submit questions
and you all who are watching this live
should feel free to submit your
questions right now and we have a small
team of people who are going to comb
through those and and I will look at
them too in real time although it's
harder for me to scroll through them so
I've got help in picking out the ones
that I'll focus upon but let me let me
jump in right now with some of the
questions that have come through as they
will get the ball rolling here so this
is from Sam main m-e-y-n sorry I'm I
always butcher names so I apologize
about that from Fort Worth Texas
and the question is on the subject of
quantum physics Sam asks what new
theories or possibilities do you foresee
being explored in the near future and
Will some of the long-standing quantum
conundrums possibly be resolved and
that's a great question I'll quickly
start by saying that there's controversy
among physicists regarding in some sense
whether there are quantum conundrums I
am of the opinion that there are many
Quantum Canon drones but there are other
of my colleagues whose perspective is
pretty far in the other direction and
they basically feel that yeah quantum
mechanics is hard for us to fully grasp
at an intuitive level but the world the
universe doesn't exist for human beings
to have an intuition about how the world
works the world exists and it's governed
by various laws quantum mechanics is
among them and all we should do is take
the mathematics of quantum mechanics and
calculate things about the world and
test those predictions and when we do
that it all works and that's all that
you can ask of a Theory of physics Niels
Bohr one of the titans of quantum
mechanics in the early days that was his
View
he was saying hey you're asking too much
if you want to really be able to tell a
full story in human terms and human
language about how the universe operates
what we should do as physicists is
understand enough about reality that we
can make predictions about what will
happen and that's what we can do with
Quantum mechanic good so that's one
perspective but as I said my perspective
is perhaps closer to yours Sam I do
think there are conundrums and the
biggest of all of those I think is the
so-called Quantum measurement problem
which is if you've ever studied quantum
mechanics you will know that there's
kind of a two-part process in quantum
mechanics there's a process where the
universe is evolving according to a
famous equation written down by Irwin
Schrodinger called the Schrodinger
equation
but then when a measurement takes place
things change
the shorten your equation no longer
governs the active measurement instead a
new process seems to take over which
selects one possible outcome from the
many Allowed by quantum physics and we
don't really understand that new process
now some would say there isn't a new
process that's a wrong way of thinking
about it this yields the many world's
interpretation of quantum mechanics but
others feel that there is a new equation
a new process something that we're
missing that we need to fill in and so
Sam your question is are we on the verge
of being able to fill that in and I wish
I could say yes I just don't know
there's a lot of exciting research
happening at the Forefront but whether
it's going to truly resolve the quantum
measurement problem in the near future I
don't I can't say and certainly I don't
think anyone else can say the other part
though that I will mention is that we're
learning a great deal about quantum
mechanics and its relation to gravity
and that relationship is one that we
long thought was a matter of blending
gravity and quantum mechanics that's how
for instance in the elegant Universe
when my book on strength that's how I
described it try to put gravity and
quantum mechanics together there was
kind of A New Perspective afoot which is
it's not so much a matter of putting
gravity and quantum mechanics together
that's secretly gravity and quantum
mechanics
are already one and the same if you
understand each of those two theories
fully and that's for instance explored
in that program I mentioned before
Einstein in the quantum if you want to
know more about it you can look there
but that to me is the most exciting
development happening at the moment
which has the chance of revolutionizing
our understanding so that's really
what's bubbling up in a significant way
at the moment okay moving onward
um
uh yes prithvik from Dubai who is one of
the students has been part of our world
science Scholars Program at the world
Science Festival which any of you you
kids who are in high school may want to
look at that as a possible program that
you may want to join in future years
it's a very vibrant approach to Bringing
really Advanced high school kids who are
really enthusiastic about science
bringing them right to the Forefront
having them engage with leading thinkers
scientists intellectuals and so forth so
at pritvik who's one of those asks
how could you test string theory and is
gravitational lensing an approach
gravitational lensing is where gravity
causes light beams to go into curved
trajectories and if you have a long
string with a lot of tension in it the
the energy in that string can cause the
light beams to bend is that one of the
main ways that we might test String
Theory well it's possible that we might
get insight into ideas of strings and
and perfect you mentioned cosmic strings
another variation on the string idea
from gravitational lensing but I think
the more likely way that we'll test
string theory
which is yet to bear fruit is through
accelerator experiments our hope is that
through powerful collisions say at the
Large Hadron Collider today but perhaps
at the linear colliders of Tomorrow we
might be able to catch a glimmer of some
of the particularly strange and new
ideas of string theory that might be
evident in that data but I'm not holding
my breath and neither should you because
string theory is such a hugely ambitious
theory that it really comes into its own
at extraordinarily High Energies
so at least in the most straightforward
version of the theory you'd have to
probe matter on such incredibly small
distances like 10 to the minus 31 32 33
centimeters such incredibly High
Energies
perhaps as much as you know a hundred
billion billion times the mass of a
proton that we don't have the ability to
probe at such small scales and high
energies yet so it has to be an indirect
approach an indirect approaches are less
convincing on paper that they will bear
fruit and so far they have not and so on
paper string theory is a powerful idea
but whether or not we'll be able to test
it I don't know I don't know so so the
thing that I would stress is if it were
somehow permanently impossible to test
during theory none of us would be
interested in it then you're not really
doing physics any longer and then I hold
that perspective and I all my colleagues
do too I would say but it's not the case
that you can't test drink it was just
really hard and that is a critical
difference we just need to rise to that
challenge and hopefully one day we will
along the same lines Luke Harris
only 12 years old Luke fantastic from
Boulder Colorado
asks um do you believe that string
theory could be the theory of everything
and why
Theory of Everything is an interesting
phrase
Luke and
it is used absolutely I tend to stay
away from that phrase because Theory of
Everything
makes it sound like anything that's not
String Theory per se is nothing and it
creates tension among physicists and so
forth and and the fact of the matter is
string theory purports to be a theory
that would describe all of Nature's
forces in all matter at a fundamental
scale but there are many other questions
that other approaches to the universe
need to be invoked you wouldn't want to
describe the motion of a baseball in
terms of the motion of its quarks using
Quantum field Theory could you do that
yes but it wouldn't give you much
Insight Newton gives you much better
insight into the motion of a baseball
than quantum physics or string theory
ever could so everything needs to be
taken in this limited context of the
basic forces and the basic ingredients
and do I think with that limited
definition of theory of everything that
string theory could be that theory I do
I do it has the makings of that but it's
very much work in progress so it is
something that we're hugely excited
about and maybe at some point you'll
work on it even the very definition of
string theory has radically changed over
the last 20 and 30 years because of our
increased understanding of what the
theory is about but could it provide in
some sense the unified theory that
Einstein is looking for absolutely
that's part of where the great
excitement comes from
Natalie
Cleaver rodos Natalie Cleaver rodos
eight years old am I reading this
correctly
wow amazing maybe maybe it's 18. Natalie
remember there's a one missing but if
you're eight wow it's amazing what are
black holes
if light cannot Escape how is it the
black holes emit some kind of x-rays
that's a good question both light and
x-rays travel at the same speed don't
they and if a black hole doesn't let
light out how could we ever see x-rays
that's a that's a great question so so
I'm glad you started with the most basic
question Natalie what are black holes
but your question suggests that you
understand the answer all too well but
I'll just quickly say it black holes
are regions of space where matter has
been put into such an extreme state
compress for instance is such high
density if we're talking about a star
say collapsing in on itself that the
warpage in space is so significant that
nothing can get out and as you rightly
say Natalie that nothing does include
light and that's why it's called a black
hole black because no light can get out
and if there's no light it looks dark it
looks black so Natalie you rightly asked
then what about these images that we've
seen I don't know if we can even bring
up an image of a black hole like the
image taken by the event arrives in
telescope where we do see light
and that in some sense is to tell tell
signature that the telescope has
received in order to let us know there's
a black hole what is that about well
it's about the following as material
falls into a black hole
it is compressed together and as that
material is compressed together it heats
up right I mean as you do this with your
hands right your hands heat up as
material brushes up against itself it
gets really hot and if it gets super hot
it can emit x-rays but here's the key
thing
the x-rays are emitted before the
material crosses the edge of the black
hole
before the material crosses the
so-called Event Horizon and x-rays that
are emitted before the material crosses
the edge that x-ray Source can yield
signatures that can reach us because
it's emitted outside the edge of the
black hole and that's how we have been
fortunate to gain insight into the real
existence of the black hole the center
of the Milky Way galaxy the black hole
the center of m87 through direct Imaging
this is something very recent and very
spectacular all our evidence for black
holes in the past was completely
indirect we would watch the orbit of
stars near the center of the Milky Way
galaxy you can see the stars whipping
around at incredibly high speeds like 10
million miles an hour and when we look
to see what the stars were orbiting
couldn't see anything at least at that
resolution but we could tell that it was
such a small region they were orbiting
that the only way that that small region
could give rise to enough gravitational
pull to whip a star around at that high
speed is that it had to be a black hole
so that was the indirect evidence and
Nobel prizes were awarded for that
Insight but the direct image of course
in some sense is the most convincing and
that's finally what we have been able to
achieve with this image that you see
right here this is the image of the
black cult the center of our galaxy a
black hole that we believe weighs on the
order four million times the mass of the
Sun 26 000 27 000 light years away and
there it is a picture
from The Event Horizon telescope
sheptolomon and his team spectacular
Discovery and you should check out our
program
about black holes where we go into that
in someday to great great question
Natalie oh there's a second black hole
question so why don't I go to that right
now
Elizabeth Hardy 14 from Miami Florida
when a black hole pulls in an object
such as a piano
I wonder why I picked a piano Elizabeth
they're like do do you love pianos or do
you hate pianos I can go either way in
trying to understand this question
Elizabeth play play your piano and
you're like no throw that thing into a
black hole or you just love pianos when
a black hole pulls in an object such as
a piano the information might get
jumbled up and then releases Hawking
radiation that's correct Elizabeth
can a black hole then re-pull or engulf
that information or does the information
pulled in always need to be in the form
of an object that's a great question
Elizabeth and first let me just
it seems like everybody in this AMA is
very well informed but let me just
mention what Hawking radiation is and
this is just a a beautiful image right
here this is not Hawking radiation but
this is you know beautiful image of the
trajectory of light beams as they are
emitted from say the X-ray hot material
falling into a black hole but let me
change gear slightly and turn to Hawking
radiation which is a Quantum process
that changes our understanding of black
holes that emerge from the classical
classical general theory of relativity
that Einstein wrote down back in 1915
and the classical Theory
once something crosses the Event Horizon
of a black hole
that's it there's just no way for it to
to ever come back out Stephen Hawking
1974 realized that if you include
Quantum processes the conclusion's a
little bit different
Quantum processes in a beautifully
subtle way that I won't go into any
detail now
allows radiation
particles to seep out just around the
edge of a black hole in a highly
unexpected way but one that he
demonstrated mathematically and there's
really no controversy any longer about
the fact that when you include Quantum
processes radiation can get out of a
black hole good okay now that radiation
We Believe must carry
the information content of anything that
fell in when you think of a piano you
might not think of it as carrying
information but of course it does
there's all sorts of information
regarding how the various atoms and
molecules in the piano are arranged
they're in a very special orderly
organized coherent pattern
and that carries information
and we believe that that information
must come out and we believe it must
come out in such a way that in principle
if you were to gather all the Hocking
radiation that seeps out from a black
hole you could recreate that piano you
could rebuild that piano from that
information no one's ever done this no
one's ever seen Hawking radiation but
this is what the mathematics tells us
and then Elizabeth is asking when the
information comes out could it then sort
of be reabsorbed by say another black
hole and yeah absolutely so as that
radiation
streams outward radiates outward that
radiation can hit other black holes it
can be swept up and indeed we believe
that that radiation again then would
ultimately be re-emitted as future
Hawking radiation it's basically a
scrambling of information from black
hole to Black Hole to black hole in a
manner that we believe conserves that
information Hawking did not believe the
information would be preserved or
conserved
for most of his life toward the end of
his life he changed his mind and agreed
with arguments that frankly initially
came from string theorists that the
information would be preserved not just
strengtheers I don't give the wrong
impression there are others who held
that view as well but String Theory had
a very dominant role in that idea
okay my screen just went black for a
moment I don't know what happened there
maybe because we're talking about black
holes but I hope that we are
still
broadcasting someone should tell me if
I'm speaking into the ether and there is
no longer a connection but I'm just
going to keep on going
let's see so zainab 18 years old from
Tehran from Tehran fantastic
can you please explain the Gaia
telescope Mission ah
well I can't say a lot about it zainab
just because I'm I'm not an expert but I
I do know that it's a European Space
Agency Mission I believe whose goal as I
recall is to give a a 3D a full 3D
stereoscopic map of the Milky Way gout
and I believe that they were going about
doing that by sampling roughly one
percent of the stars in the Milky Way
galaxy so there are about a hundred
billion stars in the galaxy so one
percent be about a billion stars and I
remember
that they were gonna
have multiple viewings of each of these
stars to really understand where they
are how they're moving and in that way
collect the first ever fully 3D map of
the Milky Way galaxy allowing us to
hopefully
gain an understanding of
a refined understanding of how the
Galaxy formed and how the Galaxy is
evolving so that's kind of the best I
can give you on that one but no doubt
there's someone in the chat who will
correct me if anything I said was
incorrect and give you more detail or
links for other things that you might
look at kriti mark on diem
15 years old from John dickarth India
I think I've said that correctly asks
where did all the stuff for the Big Bang
come from answer
I don't know that's one of the big the
big remaining Mysteries where did all
that stuff come from it's the it's the
big question you know
why is there something rather than
nothing right it's a philosophical
question or at least it sounds like one
it was raised at least in that
Incarnation that articulation by the
philosopher Gottfried leibniz but yeah
it's a question that anybody will
naturally come to when thinking about
okay we got this universe it's filled
with all the stuff where did all that
stuff come from now some physicists
would give a partial answer and and I
agree with this partial answer that the
Big Bang is certainly part of the story
so we believe according to our
cosmological theories that there was a
time roughly 13.8 billion years ago when
everything in the observable universe
was crushed together into an incredibly
small size and also in a very different
physical form as well the stuff in the
universe has changed and evolved in a
manner that we think we understand
relatively well from our understanding
of quantum field Theory but way back
then all this stuff is crushed to a very
very small size the universe then
underwent rapid expansion the big bang
that material in if we might call it a
pristine form of energy spread through
the cosmos and it transmuted into
various material forms over time
ultimately yielding the quarks the
electrons the gluons and all the stuff
that makes up the familiar physical
world around us but you can say as you
are asking critty
where did the initial stuff come from
why was there anything there at all
no real answer to that there are some
who think that per uh promising
Direction
is to imagine that maybe there really
was an era of nothingness
but maybe that era and that state is
unstable
and so maybe nothingness in some sense
zero falls apart into stuff and
anti-stuff like five and mine is five
seven and minus seven add them together
you still got zero but maybe the stuff
then evolved to create the universe that
we're familiar with and maybe there's
some anti-stuff in some anti-universe in
some sense and maybe that's where we get
something rather than nothing maybe in
totality there still is nothingness but
that nothingness has changed its
presentation into a something in an
anti-something
can you make that idea precise some have
tried some think that they have
I think the bottom line is though that
that's a deep question that we as yet do
not know the answer to
along the same lines and maybe no this
is a different question tanvir Jahan
who's 17 years old does inflation assume
a pre-existing space and if so where do
that pre-existing space come from yeah
it's a variation on the same
theme that that critty just asked
and yeah in the if you study
inflationary cosmology in college or in
graduate school you read some research
papers about it it's based on the
general theory of relativity which
assumes a pre-existing space time that
space-time can change over time it can
be dynamical and the beautiful thing in
the inflationary theory is that the
theory gives a natural explanation for
why the universe might have gone through
a period of Rapid expansion so-called
inflationary expansion there's a a
version of repulsive gravity that
inflation makes use of theoretically
makes use of in order to
seed that rapid swelling of space But
even my language betrays the assumptions
how can you have expanding space if you
don't already have space right how can
that space expand over time if you don't
already have time in the theory
and so it'd be wonderful to get to a
place where we have a theory that has no
space no time
and yet as it
describes reality whatever this more
pristine version of reality is space and
time kind of emerge
and they expand as part of their natural
Dynamics
and there are approaches to that I mean
in string theory there are ideas again
they've gone beyond their initial
Incarnation and string theory
but people have developed theories
some for instance call Matrix theories
there are some theories where the theory
just begins with matrices right
something that you studied in high
school right in essence collections of
entries arranged in an array
there's no space or time in that theory
as yet it's simply a collection of
matrices governed by certain equations
and as you study those matrices over
time you can begin to see in some sense
space emerging coordinates emerging
coordinates for space and at least in
one version coordinates for time
and so that's an idea where you start
with a theory that doesn't have space
and time built in and space and time
emerge in some dynamical manner but
again you can say well where'd the
matrices come from and and and and and
and where did the idea or the construct
of mathematics to describe reality
what's the basis for for that as the
right language and so on
these are tough questions and at some
point at least as a working physicist
you say great questions keep it in the
back of my mind and I'm just going to
assume there's a space in time and go
forward from there and try to understand
the world as best as I possibly can with
that as a starting point and perhaps
leave over to Future generations to go
even further back even more fundamental
but those of course are are great great
questions
um Orion aloke 16.
are there physically viable ways to
construct closed time-like curves
and which of physicists think of uh the
novacov self-consistency principle and
so forth yeah so
again this is in more plain language the
question of time travel right we're used
to the fact that you can go into Loops
in space right you do that all the time
can you go into Loops in time right not
Loops in space but Loops in time where
you might Circle back in time to an
earlier moment and in that way in some
sense it traveled to your past
um
there are ideas that people have put
forward for how such Loops might emerge
black holes are are one idea that people
have put forward where if you have black
holes connected by wormholes traveling
through a black hole Through the
Wormhole and so forth might be able to
take you to the pass by virtue of
traversing this tunnel through space and
time called the wormhole I would be
hesitant to say that these are viable
ways it's not like someone's going to go
out and do this
we can't in any volitional way with our
level of understanding control black
holes that we've never encountered a
world but we don't even know if they're
actually real mathematically they make
sense and so forth so
these are beautiful ideas that have been
developed by Forefront thinkers but I
would not say that they're I don't think
anyone would say that they're viable
ways to actually create them
all right Linda
from Toronto let's see what we have here
um it's a Multiverse question so if
science tells us that we live in a
Multiverse in which everything even the
laws of physics Linda asks would be
different if we happen to live in a
different part of that Multiverse how
can anything that we see in our
particular part of the universe be
predicted scientifically
it seems that there must always be many
possibilities uh it's a great question
Linda and you're right you're absolutely
right
Multiverse theories
do inherently run up against a
particular challenge which is if the
flavor of Multiverse there are many
different kinds of Multiverse theories
but let's go to the Limit if the flavor
of Multiverse that someone is discussing
allows for all manner of universe with
all manner of possibility all manner of
different starting conditions all manner
of ways that that universe may have
evolved over time
then you can imagine being in the
unfortunate situation that any
particular prediction that a theory
might make would hold true in some
Multiverse
I didn't say that correct it would hold
true in some universe that's a member of
that Multiverse that's what Linda's
point is and if that's the case how
would you ever prove a given Theory
wrong
right because if it makes some
prediction it could be true in a
different universe and moreover if it
makes a prediction that's true in our
universe how do you know you're not just
in some sense molding the prediction to
match what we see whereas in a different
Universe in the Multiverse it would have
a different character
so it does challenge the issue of of
falsifiability because even some of the
predictions that you hold dear
are only true in this particular
universe and if they had turned out
differently they would have been true in
a different universe and therefore what
do you do in that
situation
a some would say throw away the
Multiverse for that reason it's no
longer doing science because if anything
that can happen does happen somewhere
then the
version of Science in which you make
unique predictions and you test them
kind of goes a little bit out the window
others think that that is too strong a
reaction
and rather perhaps if you understand the
Multiverse well enough maybe you can do
Multiverse demographics maybe you can
figure out
the fraction of universes in which
certain qualities would hold and maybe
it's the case that you know in 99 of
those universes a certain quality holds
and if our universe has that quality you
can make a theory that predicts that
quality you would consider that a
success maybe the Multiverse allows for
in that sense
some kind of statistical reasoning that
makes certain qualities more likely and
if you're a typical member of that
Multiverse you should have that quality
and if you look out in the world and you
measure it and you do have that quality
then that would be one particular
feather in that theoretical multiverses
hat
either way and it's controversial some
say Multiverse ideas are not scientific
for the reasons that you suggest
others think that that would be far too
restrictive in our understanding of what
a theory is and what the universe is
like and so I think only time will tell
if these ideas are sufficiently fruitful
that they become part of the Lexicon of
how we how we describe the universe
Suzanne Walsh
17 years old from Green New York Green
New York I don't think that's far from
where I am right now up here in the
Casco mountains
Susan Suzanne I should say ask I believe
that time is already present already
there past present and future are all in
existence so are the stages of evolution
and by Evolution I think Suzanne means
dynamical change are they already there
too right in some senses everything just
out there already in its temporal
location is what Suzanne is asking
according to
the classical version of Einstein's
ideas
the answer would kind of be yes right
there's a so-called block Universe
perspective that naturally emerges
from this way of thinking about the
world where
we are all comfortable that that all of
space is out there right I don't think
that's sort of a idea that's
controversial among most people though I
have to say among philosophers some
physicists it is but
if we say that all of space is out there
right now
the idea is to take that same kind of
reasoning to argue that all of time is
also out there so if each
if if you think about all of space as
sort of one giant slice of bread
and all the space at the next moment of
time is another slice of bread next to
it and all space at a subsequent motion
of time is another slice of bread
the idea is that this full Cosmic loaf
is already in existence now how do you
argue for that well
it's not hard actually you study a
little bit of Einstein's ideas and in
relativity we learn
that what's now for me might be the
future for somebody else who's moving
relative to me or what's now my slice of
bread which now for me might be the past
for somebody else that's moving relative
to me or part of my slice may be in
their past and this is the beauty of the
relativity of simultaneity a quality of
the special theory of relativity where
if two people are moving relative to
each other their definition of now their
definition of what's happening at this
moment their definition of simultaneity
their definitions are different
and when you take that into account you
get this idea of the past of one person
could be the future of somebody else and
then you simply say to yourself look you
know
if you take all observers all people on
equal footing then what I consider to be
the past might be there now right what I
consider to be the future might be
someone's now so if you put all the Nows
together of all possible observers
moving with all possible speeds in all
possible directions throughout the
cosmos you fill out that entire Cosmic
loaf not just all of space in one moment
but all space at all moments
and that gives us notion that all of
time is out there and this is you know
I've said this before in some of these
live sessions but it gives rise to this
um at least in the mind of Einstein this
very beautiful quote when the Widow of a
close friend of his they were in
communication and in reference to his
friend that had passed away
he said
you know to we convince physicists the
distinction between past present and
future it's only an illusion however
persistent so time Stein's way of
thinking the human mind focuses upon its
own notion of now its own notion of
simultaneous 1080 its own notion of
what's happening at a given moment
but that's a very local and subjective
description of the world the more
objective description come back to the
question Suzanne's question which uh has
now is escaped from my screen or maybe
it wasn't Susan who asked this question
in Green New York oh gosh I'm sorry
somehow my uh maybe someone can tell me
who asked this question I forget but yes
the idea would be that all of time is
out there and so when you talk about
Evolution dynamical change in some sense
it is already imprinted in that way of
thinking about the world all of those
events and the relationships between
each other over what we subjectively
call time is already out there too
now is this a dominant perspective among
physicists I don't know I haven't really
done a survey I think many would agree
with this quantum mechanics does
complicate things to some extent but
there's a version of this that's
compatible with our Quantum ideas too so
where I pressed yeah I I certainly would
take this as my perspective on how the
world is put together
all right moving onward let's see what
else we have here maybe some questions
that have just come in as um
I don't know if I don't I don't let me
just quickly go to uh
well I have here oh gosh it's scrolling
by too quickly for me to uh
to read uh and it's too hard for me to
pick one out so if any of my my team can
pick out some interesting question that
just came in I'd be happy to take a look
but I'm going to continue on with uh
this long list of questions that I've
already come in uh Alan Powell chemistry
teacher from Brooklyn New York Brooklyn
New York fantastic
from the USA Hyde Leadership Charter
School it sounds sounds great one of my
students Alan Powell says
um yeah so so I need to have a quite
technical thing so so my own team
stopped putting anything in this in this
document because every time you put
something in it Scrolls away and I
completely lose my place so
um no more uh using this document at all
and I'll just uh go back and forth
between this and the YouTube channel but
I remember what the question was the
question was one of the students of Alan
Powell asked what is a Quantum vacuum
what is a Quantum vacuum and that is an
incredibly good and subtle question I
mean normally vacuum right it's it's
emptiness right that's that's what you
think
and in a classical world the concept of
emptiness is very very straightforward
it's just there's like no matter there's
no energy there's no stuff that's what
we mean by the classical vacuum and
quantum mechanics Things become much
more subtle because of the uncertainty
principle right and the uncertainty
principle we learn
according to quantum physics coming from
Heisenberg that there are qualities of
the world that you can't nail down
simultaneously for instance you can't
know the position of a particle and its
momentum simultaneously you can know one
you can't know the other when you
translate that into the language of
fields right we know that the world is
full of fields the electromagnetic field
electric Fields magnetic fields
gravitational field and other more
exotic versions of fields when you
translate the uncertainty principle
into the language of fields it tells you
that you can't know the value of a field
and how quickly that value is changing
it's like position and speed but now
you're talking about the value of a
field and how quickly it's changing what
does that mean it means that I can't
tell you that in the vacuum the value of
a field is zero and it's not changing if
I tell you that the value is zero it
actually means that it's changing rather
rapidly if I nail down how it's changing
I might be able to then not tell you
what its value is and so forth so so the
point is if your intuition from
classical physics is
a vacuum is nothing zero field zero
change so that it stays zero quantum
mechanics says you can't have that
configuration so there's always some
jitteriness to the value of a field
and the amazing thing is we can measure
that jitteriness of the field way back
in 1948 Hendrick Casimir
proposed
experiments to test the so-called
Casimir effect
that if you adequately focus in on a
region of empty space there should be
some Quantum undulations and those
undulations would show up in certain
experiments as metal plates that are
surrounding that vacuum being drawn
together or being pushed apart by
emptiness by empty space empty space
drawing the plates together or pushing
them apart and they do the experiments
and they confirm
this prediction so the quantum vacuum is
really something
that reflects this underlying Quantum
uncertainty so that's a it's a great
question and uh as you see quite
quite a subtle one all right carrying on
let's see what else we have here
um maybe we can change our topic a
little bit to oh here's a here's one
um Alexa Briggs
from bitter Ford Maine
it's interesting I understand
how we probably asked the high school
kids to give their age but everybody
everybody gave their age
um I'm not gonna divulge to the ages
that were given but Alexa is not a kid
well maybe kid at heart you know but a
little bit older but a kid compared to
me I'm like oh man now
all right so what exciting new
information do you think we'll learn
from the James Webb Space Telescope
about
black hole so yeah the James Webb Space
Telescope
have you guys been following it again
that was one of our other
I don't even think I mentioned that
program at the outset I don't recall
that's another uh program that we
recently did and uh if you are around I
should say on on July 12th that's not
far from now right about two weeks from
now NASA is going to release the first
images from the James Webb Space
Telescope on the morning of July 12th
and sometime during the day of July 12th
we'll do one of these live sessions to
talk with
some of the scientists responsible for
those images to get a sense of
what the telescope has found and how
it's working and is the data coming in
in the way that they expected
already you may have caught that there
was a press conference yesterday where
they noted that the launch went so
smoothly
that they didn't have to use much of the
onboard fuel to get the telescope in the
right configuration the right position
so while they had budgeted fuel for a
10-year Mission because it went so
smoothly it looks like they'll have a
20-year Mission wow right Gathering data
for for 20 years instead of 10 so so
there's a lot that the James Webb is
going to discover Alexa's question is
what will the James Webb tell us about
about black holes
I don't know I'm not sure certainly
black holes again are one of those grand
Cosmic Mysteries
but at the moment it's really The Event
Horizon telescope that has the the uh
the dibs if you will on on black holes
the most exciting
research that is going to come sort of
more from the kind of physics that I'm
interested in from the arena of say
gravity and from cosmology is it's
possible that the James Webb Telescope
will give insight into what's come to be
known as the Hubble tension I don't know
if you're familiar with this Alexa or
everybody else but when you measure the
expansion rate of the universe using
different methodologies
some methods and the accompanying
theoretical ideas focus on the early
universe and some focus on more recent
times and when you compare the expansion
rate of the universe in these two
different epochs if you will sort of
early and late they don't seem to match
up there seems to be a mismatch between
the expansion rate now mismatches or
misunderstandings
um different predictions based on
observation and theory for what the
expansion rate from B has
really dogged cosmology since the
earliest days of the subject and over
time those mismatches have been brought
into alignment this is a little bit
different those earlier versions were
focused on the same Epoch and they were
just different observations different
techniques that were giving different
answers now we're really looking at
different epochs so maybe the mismatch
is real and what we'll learn maybe from
the telescope is how things change over
time to bring what seems like a mismatch
into alignment so there may be a deeper
understanding that emerges here may not
simply be oh those measurements had
arrows or those measurements weren't as
precise so they were doing the
calibration in one way or another this
may be a deeper Insight revealed by
resolving this tension in these
different measurements and these
different approaches to measuring and
understanding from Theory the expansion
rate of the universe syllable hang tight
I don't think we'll have any insight on
the 12.
the insights in the 12 will more from
the initial imagery and maybe there's
something exciting I certainly have
heard I guess in the press conference
yesterday that they will be revealing
the deepest image that Humanity has ever
taken of the cosmos that's exciting
right to go
further back in time and further out in
space than any previous
observation right that's huge that's
exciting so that's great but I don't
think there'll be any detailed
scientific
upheavals revolutions or concordances
coming from these early releases but who
knows who knows we'll see we'll see on
the 12th uh again a black hole black
holes are on people's minds it's great
Margaret feaster from Tallahassee
Florida
asks the recent images of the two black
holes both look as though there is an
accretion disk right but is this just
because the way it would look from every
angle no actually there really are
accretion discs and you know one of the
interesting I don't know if it was a
surprise but certainly some people seem
to express some surprise is that the
accretion disk for the
Milky Way galaxies black hole
Sagittarius A star that this seems to be
facing us face on when some thought it
would be more at an angle and there's
some interesting discussion about why
that is maybe has to do with the way our
galaxy may have gone through an earlier
merger with another galaxy that may have
given an orientation for Sagittarius A
star the black hole and so forth I'm not
an expert on on the details here but
yeah the idea is that it seems to be
a ubiquitous quality of black holes that
as material falls and kind of Smooths
itself out it squeezes itself down into
a pancake-like structure this accrution
disc and it's the intense heat from the
frictional forces acting between the
ingredients and those accretion discs as
they spiral into the black hole that
gives rise to the heat that generates
the x-rays that we spoke about earlier
allowing us a visual imprint of the
conditions near the edge of a black hole
one of the things the Event Horizon
telescope is going to be doing
is really focusing in on the Event
Horizon
focusing on photons as they go into
orbit around black holes Photon sphere
as it's called and then going even
closer to the edge and this is where we
may get some surprising new insights so
uh it is really
an enormous achievement to be able to
see black holes in the ways that we do
now but this is as if you look at our
program with Shepstone he emphasizes
repeatedly in that that this really is
the beginning really is the beginning
they're going to not just have still
images they're going to have movies
dynamical images of black holes and over
time I think we're gonna have a lot of
great surprises emerge and old Mysteries
resolved and new ones revealed so yes I
think it's an incredibly exciting time
as we go forward
uh Tom
from I'm not sure how this is uh
pronounced but
Mexico sorry I'm clearly that's not how
you how you pronounce it I have to go
back to uh
my high school Spanish to remember
yalisco Mexico I don't know I'm going to
stop embarrassing myself here but the
question is how does the curvature of
space-time relate to gravity how does
the curvature space time relate to
gravity and yeah that's a that's a key
question that underlies everything
really that we've been talking about
here today
answer is is is subtle but simple
Einstein taught us that gravity is the
curvature of space and time so as
something Falls and Einstein's
description it's rolling along a curve
an indentation in the space-time fabric
it's okay to have a two-dimensional
image in mind you can think about a
rubber sheet with a heavy object in it
and something is just rolling along the
rubber sheet as a rough metaphor a rough
visualization of Einstein found as I've
emphasized repeatedly in previous q and
A's you gotta take that imagery with the
grain of salt you see an image of it
coming up right here you see the sun is
warping the environment around it and
the planets in some sense are following
the indentation in the space-time fabric
that's a two-dimensional vision of the
fabric of space it's really a
three-dimensional Vision right and it's
a little harder
to to picture in fact we do have a 3D
version of these visuals I don't think
our team will be able to pull it up in
real time but if they could that gives a
somewhat clearer imagery but the rough
idea is that an object merely by being
in space
warps the environment and then other
objects moving through that warped
environment go along interesting curved
trajectories because they're now moving
through the curved environment that the
initial object create and that is
Einstein's vision
of what the force of gravity is in fact
some would say
we shouldn't even use the language force
of gravity any longer gravity some would
like to say is not a force gravity is
the curvature of space-time and that's
all that it is now using the language of
forces is still fruitful
for many many ordinary motions under the
influence of gravity using the language
of forces is the most sensible way to go
but yes fundamentally Einstein did
rewrite our understanding of what
gravity is Shifting it from a Newtonian
Force at a distance to a local curvature
of space-time
Jacqueline Giles from Exeter UK says or
asks I should say how do we know
that there was only one big bang and not
two or more at the same time and
Jacqueline we don't you're right and I
don't know if you joined us a little bit
late and I didn't use this language but
there were earlier questions about the
Multiverse the possibility that there
are many universes that our universe is
not the only Universe one way that there
might be a Multiverse is exactly
embedded in your question there could
have been multiple big bangs
our big bang could have given rise to
this realm that we live within and are
familiar with but there could have been
other Big Bangs giving rise to other
Realms that would rightly be called
universes of their own so it could be
big bang upon big bang big bang and so
forth and those Realms might have
different matter be governed by somewhat
different forces
have different macroscopic structures
some might be lifeless some might be
teeming with life and so forth and so
yes there's there's nothing that
establishes the uniqueness of the big
bang and that's one of the motivations
for at least considering the possibility
not saying it's true but considering the
possibility that our universe is one of
many that we live in a Multiverse all
right pressing onward Ruth
from Orlando Florida
no age for Ruth so I don't know if Ruth
is
um among the younger or the more mature
in our audience but this is an equal
opportunity access AMA and the question
is I don't understand what it means to
find solutions to Einstein's or anyone
else's uh equations yeah yeah what does
it mean to find Solutions so I you know
what we do
in physics is we commit to the language
of mathematics to describe the external
world
and for instance if we're describing the
motion of the baseball we describe its
position with a coordinate that
basically says how far the baseball is
from its starting location it's a number
but we want to figure out what that
number is and how that number changes in
time
how do we figure out how that distance
from the starting location changes in
time I mean to be concrete Aaron judge
Yankees Slugger hits a baseball from
home plate it soars toward the Outfield
bleachers he's done that 29 times so far
this season but that's a different story
we want to know where that baseball is
as a function of time and so we describe
it using coordinates that give a height
a distance from home plate and so forth
and we can be more precise about that
but its coordinates that change as a
function of time as the ball is moving
we have an equation called Newton's
Second Law details don't matter but
there's an equation like the equations
that you studied in algebra and perhaps
even in Calculus if you studied the
equation there and that equation
dictates how these coordinates change in
time and we seek a solution of that
equation
a solution of that equation tells us how
the coordinates change in time so you
have the basic equation the basic
initial conditions how hard and at what
angle Aaron judge hit the ball and then
you plug that into Newton's equations
and you solve those equations to get X
as a function of T position as a
function of time that's a very simple
example Einstein's equation is the one
that you talk about philosophically no
different mathematically and technically
much more complicated those equations I
don't know if we have them but they talk
about the curvature of space-time R mu
Nu minus a half G mu Nu R equals eight
Pi G over C to the fourth T mu Nu it's a
non-linear
partial differential equation for
distance relationships in space time
that's what it is it's an equation what
does it mean to solve it
you tell me the matter and energy within
a region of space for instance you tell
me there's the Sun and then I look at
those differential equations as a
mathematician would and I find the
solution to the equations what function
when I stick it into the differential
equation solves so that the left hand
side and the right hand side are equal
and then given that solution I can
interpret what it means the curvature of
space-time is
the way that we interpret the results to
Einstein's equations Einstein's
mathematics I hope Ruth that that gives
you some sense of what we mean by
solving an equation and interpreting it
for what it tells us about the nature of
the world all right what else do we have
oh prior Dash boy that's a name I
haven't heard in a long time I guess we
haven't done these live sessions in a
while we were doing them quite
frequently during the thick moments the
thick months of the pandemic now with
things partially opened up we haven't
been doing this as often
but yeah this naturally fits into
exactly
um that same series and pryog was a was
a key audience member in that series and
asks here what is Bell's theorem and how
is it related to Quantum indeterminacy
yeah right wow big important question
let me just give a kind of brief answer
to it which is this
so
in quantum mechanics as I said before
there is this uncertainty principle
which tells us that we can't know for
instance as I said the position and the
momentum of a particle simultaneously
but that raises an interesting question
does a particle actually have
a position and a speed and we just can't
gain access to those qualities
or is it really the case that a particle
simply cannot possess
a position and a speed simultaneously
the latter description that a particle
simply can't have both of those
qualities is the one that is dominant in
most physicists thinking about quantum
mechanics but
the possibility that particles do have
positions and momentum we just can't get
at them
is an interesting possibility that would
restore
a quality of the classical World a
quality of the
previous description of the world before
quantum mechanics that many people held
dear right if you were to ask Isaac
Newton
what is reality I mean how would you
articulate reality I think Newton would
have said something like I will tell you
at a given moment in time the positions
and the speeds the positions and the
velocities of everything was out there
every physical ingredient right down to
the most fine ingredients that he didn't
know about but we subsequently do is
that a wrong picture of reality so
Bell's theorem sought to give insight
into whether it could be the case that
objects can possess these
forbidden quality simultaneous and we
simply can't get out them Einstein's
view was that
particles do have these qualities Emma
Rover and the second part of Bell's
theorem is Einstein also believed that
there is no way that there could be
so-called non-local influences
doing something here will affect
something here Einstein said and most
physicists would have agreed whereas
quantum mechanics raises the possibility
of what you're doing here having an
intricate interrelationship with
something that happens far away this is
the idea of quantum entanglement so
Bell's theorem fits squarely in this
question of are there non-local
influences can objects possess quality
simultaneously the quantum uncertainty
says that they can't
so Belle wrote down a beautiful result a
testable result to try to get some
insight into this issue having to do
with particles that are entangled and
whether or not they have the qualities
that a classical physicist would ascribe
to them bottom line is the most precise
interpretation of the results testing
Bells theorem Bell's inequality
is that the einsteinian image
of a local Universe where particles have
all qualities that classical physicists
said that they should have that that
that is ruled out
that seems to be ruled out by the
experiments testing Bell's theorem now
what part of it is ruled out most of us
interpret it as ruling out that the
universe is local that the Universe does
have these non-local influences it turns
out that in principle particles can have
positions and momentum simultaneously we
just can't get at it if there are these
non-local influences that quantum
mechanics needs to provide and that's
the Insight that John Bell gave and it
was a beautiful Insight because prior to
his work people would say what do you
what do you mean a particle has a
position and a momentum and just can't
get at it that is what we mean by not
having those qualities if you can't get
at them then they're not real
and Bell amazingly found a way to test
the idea that a particle could have
these qualities they're inaccessible and
yet they could be real because they
would influence the outcome of
experiments
and that was a game changer yielding to
the results that I just described okay
that was probably a longer answer than I
intended to give but let's do a few more
questions here before we wrap up and I'm
just going to quickly look at our list
of
things that we have here
um
uh
let's see do uh well here's a simple one
Vania asked do you plan to come up with
a a new book soon and uh not at the
moment I'm not writing a book at the
moment they're huge undertaking I do
have ideas for two or three books
um I'm working on some cool stuff in in
the pedagogy of quantum mechanics so if
you guys want to learn more about
quantum mechanics and some of the things
that I've been talking about stay tuned
sign up World Science Festival we're
going to be doing some very interesting
approaches to Bringing quantum mechanics
who have broad audience so so
stay tuned for that
um
let's see what else we have here
anything else
um
um
let's see
um
ah here's a question on Dark Energy we
haven't spoken about dark matter and
dark energy so the question is what's
the latest in our thinking about uh dark
energy and uh again very briefly dark
energy this this incredible mystery that
came to light in its most forceful way
in 1998
scientists examining the expansion rate
of the universe found that the expansion
is speeding up over time crazy idea when
you think about gravity in its usual
Incarnation as an attractive pull right
if the universe is expanding the pull of
every Galaxy on every other should yield
things that constrain The Exodus slowing
it down over time
but we found through Nobel prize winning
results observations that The Exodus is
speeding up over time not slowing down
and so how's that happening best
explanation we have is dark energy
giving our eyes to where pulsive push
that's pushing everything apart
amazingly an Einstein's general theory
of relativity if there is an energy
suffusing space uniformly
not the clumpy stuff they give rise to
ordinary attractive crap but if there's
a energy spread uniformly through space
he gives rise to repulsive gravity
repulsive gravity to push everything
apart and so that's our best explanation
but
we've never measured the dark energy
we've never seen it directly we don't
really really understand its qualities
does it change over time is it static
will it get stronger over time causing
things to move away even faster at a
faster accelerator rate than they are
today might it decay over time so yeah
things are moving apart ever more
quickly now but perhaps in the future
they won't perhaps in the future will
slow down and maybe attract each other
and collapse back in on themselves all
deep questions that I would say is we
don't really have any new insight in
there are machines there are
observatories there are observational
platforms being developed that we'll be
studying both dark matter and dark
energy over time
so stay tuned for that one but at the
moment this big mystery and it is big in
the sense of even numerically something
like 70 percent of the energy but in the
entire universe we believe is tied up in
Dark Energy so however much we think
we've made progress and understand the
world than we have of most of that has
been focused on
objects that constitute a very small
fraction
of all that there is
Dark Energy some 70 Dark Matter
something like 25 24
so the vast majority of the universe is
stuff that we've yet to fully identify
and so that is on the horizon going
forward
wow so this has been a good hour and
change
answering some of your questions
I appreciate your your tuning in and
again I will remind you July 12th we
will have another live session where we
will talk about the new results from the
James Webb Space Telescope that will be
released on the morning of July 12th you
should sign up for our newsletters that
you get uh announcement when our new
programs are released on YouTube some of
you have asked when are we going back to
live programming in the sense of
everybody in the theater sitting
together I think the first we will do of
those is this fall in New York city so
if you're around New York City I think
we're going to do at least one live
event if not more in the fall but the
full Festival full Live Events we are
planning
for our usual time slot Sometime Late
May early June of 2023 but if you are in
Australia we will be doing our live
event sometime in March of 2023 in the
meantime we will continue to produce
this online content we'd love to hear
your suggestions for areas of science
you would like us to explore upcoming
programs really cool program on
psychedelics coming up cool program on
dreaming cool program on how we can
enhance the human form interesting
program on our the historic prehistoric
roots of our species and other humanoid
species that we co-existed with in the
past mated with as the program will make
clear in the past and so stay tuned for
all of those upcoming programs and with
that I will bring this ask me anything
live q a to a close thank you so much
for your attention looking forward to
interacting with you in future live
sessions
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you